Why don't we speak next to.
Oh, I don't know.
I mean, there's so many different people interested
in getting on.
Why don't we go to Treh from Seattle, treh
from Seattle?
You're on the air.
Hello, can you hear me?
Yes, I can.
Hey, David, I was just wondering, what do
you think the future of the Republican Party
is too soon to know.
Too soon to know?
I think that, you know, so what we see right
now is a power struggle.
Donald Trump at his CPAC speech saying here's
a list of Republicans that are bad and that
I'm going to try to defeat and you can donate
to me.
I will be the kingmaker in twenty twenty two.
On the other hand, you have some Republicans
who remain behind Donald Trump, others who
want the Republican Party to get out from
Trump.
You have a legal battle right now where the
Republican Party is saying we can use Trump's
name and likeness to fundraise, whereas Trump
is saying stop using my name, people should
donate to me and I'll decide who is going
to win in the Republican Party.
We just have to wait and see in twenty, twenty
two who wins and who loses.
Do Marjorie Taylor Greene and Lauren Bobert
and Madison Cathar and get reelected or do
they get humiliated and made one term Trump
and radicals?
I just think we don't know yet what the future
of the party is.
Interesting, yeah, I I've done a lot of research
on to kind of the evolution of the Republican
Party, and I have found that it's almost as
if each generation has tried to out conservative
the other, but not Trump.
I mean, Trump saying, oh, until Trump.
Yeah, right.
Because because Trump ran on a whole different
paradigm, which was just kind of shock value
and faux populism.
Right.
Yeah.
I went from, you know, Richard Nixon, EPA,
like you said, I believe at one point to.
You know, Kuhnen crazies like Marjorie Taylor
Green, right, but in the middle of that, in
the middle, there's there's important stuff
in the middle, which was Reaganomics and then
the radicalization of Newt Gingrich and then
the sort of dimwitted George W. Bush and then
the racism inspired by Obama.
And that all culminated in Trump.
Right.
Yeah.
And my last question for you is about the
Green New Deal.
Sure.
What do you think we could do to modify it
or make it less radical?
Which parts are radical?
Bosa which parts are radical?
Well, forgive me, I haven't read the entire
bill.
So is there any of it that you can point to
that's radical?
One hundred percent relying 100 percent on
renewable energy by what date?
I'm sorry.
Well, that's only radical if we say that it's
going to be by three years from now, right.
Like eventually it wouldn't be radical to
say at some point we should get to that.
It becomes a question of when is it reasonable,
right?
Yeah, I hope I hope that the bill is meaning
that this is going to be a more smooth transition
towards that.
And I want that to happen.
Yeah, not so abruptly.
It happened abruptly because we don't have
the supply.
You know, anybody who's scared that abruptly
we're going to have to be only be depending
on wind.
We don't have the supply by definition.
It will have to be a, you know, a relatively
long transition.
Right.
Well, thank you very much, David.
No problem.
Yeah, but I find the parts that you find to
be radical.
And then let's talk again.
Oh, yes.
Yes.
All right.
Good.
Straight from Seattle.
Very good.
Yeah.
I mean, if you if you're going to say it's
if you're going to say it's radical, you've
got to tell me what is radical and.
Yeah.